there's gonna be a Star Trek musical
Strange New World's Musical
I'm not joking
but is it a step too far
welcome to Sidetrack here Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
when I actually first saw this because
it was announced at San Diego Comic-Con
I thought well that's a joke haha that's
not real
it is there is going to be a strange New
World's musical it's going to be the
ninth episode of this run
it's going to stream in the first couple
of days of September and there are going
to be 10 original songs including one
that's a version of Bohemian Rhapsody
the episode is called Subspace Rhapsody
and I'm not joking it's this isn't a
joke this is real
[Music]
hello
what do I think about this
when I saw the announcement for the
lower decks crossover where boiler is
going to be joining the crew and going
to be on strange new worlds with
Marinette I thought well that's the
stupidest idea I've ever heard in my
life
um how's that going to work
luckily the ACT is The Voice
those characters are well known likeable
actors so you know there's going to be
live action but I actually said at the
time look that's either going to be
amazing or awful dude this is nothing
compared to you know that Pike thing we
aren't supposed to talk about there's
nothing in between it really depends how
they execute it
I've now seen the episode they executed
it brilliantly and it is one of those
great episodes of Star Trek a bit like
Deep Space Nine you know all the trouble
with triple sort of episodes they've
done
um or when we've seen Mirror Universe
episodes and things
it does have that sort of feel to it and
it is a great episode of Star Trek
so
strangely Walters already sort of pushed
that boat out and taken a few risks that
you know other Star Trek shows might not
have done
um or other shows that only get a 10
episode run might not have done
we've already had a couple of Comedy
episodes as well not just the crossover
but you know Spock becoming human was
very much a comedy episode again in the
tradition of Star Trek
but we've had really know two of those
episodes You could argue kind of three
when are we actually going to get some
action or some actual sort of Adventure
in this series
not sure so that's really my first
problem with this musical idea we only
get 10 episodes of strange new rules
Star Trek real estate Star Trek time is
quite valuable we only get 10 hours of
it
now if they were going to do a musical
as part of a 22 episode run
and it was just you know a light-hearted
fun episode just to break up you know
the normal Adventures
I would never have any problem with it
but it's not it's the end of the second
season it's only the second season as
well don't forget that doesn't really
have much point to it other than to be
light-hearted and fun I can't really
imagine it's going to you know push the
boundaries of what Star Trek is or you
know if any big Revelations about the
characters and things I might give us a
bit of character development it looks
like Kirk and Khan are gonna open bed
together which isn't irony and other
than that
it's just going to be an awful lot of
singing
ohura in the trailer does say people
celebrate through song
but then there are large dance
choreographed sequences
this is still science fiction
if I want to watch a musical I'm going
to go watch
I don't really want to watch a musical
but this is supposed to be science
fiction it is supposed to be based in
some sort of reality it does look like
there's some sort of like energy wave
that hits the crew and that's what makes
them all start singing I suspect doesn't
probably you know guessing there but
that's what it looks like
so
um at least when Buffy did this and they
did like a musical episode they sort of
it was like a demon that was causing it
or something
by the way a musical episode that wasn't
bad the songs are okay and everything
you know just Sweden does like writing
music and he's actually quite good at it
um but that is universally loved oh no
no sorry hated by Buffy fans when I
watch Buffy as soon as we get to the
musical episode I skip it and I watch
The Next Episode I don't want to watch
it now I may enjoy this episode of um
Bohemian Rhapsody gone to space but I
don't think I'll ever watch it again and
that's another reason why this is a bit
of a risk for strange new worlds
particularly in the streaming Universe
where re-watches really matter if this
was season seven of strangely worlds
they were coming to the end of the life
of strange new worlds then again I can
understand why they would do this
um again like a bit of fun showing off
The Wider skills of the actors which you
know the actors love they get I'm gonna
get to sing in this episode of brilliant
I went to Juilliard for four years I
finally got to sing
um
Aurora's character by the way looks like
she can really sing but um I couldn't
stand this then again it's a bit of a
celebration of strange new world it's a
bit of a celebration of the actors you
know
um
but get it but it's the end of the
second season I don't think they've
earned the right to do this episode yet
this reminds me a little bit of Stargate
sg1 when they did their 200th episode
a quite a silly episode they basically
let the creators just do whatever they
wanted you know the screenwriters just
went nuts we saw you know Team America
Stargate and one more extreme and stuff
like this it's not an episode I've ever
really re-watched it was glorious at the
time because of what it was it was the
200th episode so yeah they just went
crazy
strange new world hasn't earned a 200th
episode yet they haven't earned a 20th
episode yet
so I'm not sure they have earned the
right to do this
Maybe
as I've said the track time at the
moment is valuable we only get 10 hours
of these characters
I do want to see some comedy I do want
to see a monster of the week sort of
episodic cycle of Star Trek I do like
that they're sort of doing Gene
Roddenberry Star Trek again I like the
feel of these I like the type of
episodes
I thought the first episode of strange
new worlds this season wasn't very good
they stole the Enterprise to go and save
Khan
it from beginning to end particularly
wasn't a particularly good episode but
also just logically like they're just
forgive and forget at the end of that
you know they're just like oh you stole
the Enterprise don't worry about it they
don't even get a snack on the wrist spot
doesn't get demoted or anything
um I didn't like how Pike wasn't in that
episode after all and he was barely in
the second episode I have logical
problems with the second episode as well
with the court case
um you get Asylum so All Is Forgiven
that makes no logical sense
um but then we've had a couple of really
good episodes and I've really started to
get into the series again I'm not at
that point yet of oh it's Thursday start
exchanging rules has come out always get
up early and watch it before I have to
go to work like I did with Picard season
three not yet but I am enjoying it
I just wish that we were going to get a
bit more Star Trek a bit more of an
adventure episodes because they all seem
to be light-hearted comedy at the moment
I do want to see those episodes where
something bad happens they've hinted
that something really bad is coming with
the gone
um or some other threat we don't really
know 100 certain
but this episode takes at least one
episode away from the end of the series
you know a couple of episodes finale
where we could have seen something you
know a bit more dramatic
doesn't feel like this Series has a much
balance at the moment Star Trek is a bit
light-hearted it should be
a bit fun it should have the episodes
where you know we get a transported
disaster and time travel episode you
should have these quirky episodes as
well but stranger world seems to be
having a lot of them
so is it a bit too far into the quirky
funny silliness for strange new worlds
well the crossover episode did concern
me I did think it was either going to be
brilliant or awful and now we've seen it
it's brilliant
they really did nail it they got the
tone just right for me it was funny it
was quirky but it also did give us some
Star Trek again so it was great
if they nail the musical out even if it
is great
I will probably only ever watch it once
I will probably never watch it again
whereas I will watch the lower decks
crossover episode again
so this is a risk for me and it's a risk
that I'm not sure is going to succeed
for strange new worlds even if the
episode is good
I don't think it'll succeed as strangely
was because I'm not gonna watch it again
so I tip my hat to the creators this is
Brave
but I'd also like a little bit more
Adventure and action in this series
Discovery was all action and eventually
don't get me wrong and that didn't work
but we're gonna need to find a balance
for strange new worlds but hey guys get
some comments tell me what you think is
this musical idea just stupid or do you
actually think hey it's different
franchises need to be different to
succeed and at the end of the day this
could be a lot of fun
or do you just think about the Buffy
episode where they did this
well the boys episode where they did
this or other series when they've done
this
and they just make a cringe
I'm in a little bit of the cringe area
at the moment but I've got an open mind
and I'm willing to give it a chance and
I will give it a chance
hope you guys do too
hey if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out while
we get these videos out to you as
quickly as we can also you can follow
all these Links at the bottom for all of
the scytrex stuff
live on gun Prosper I would have sung
that but I'm not going to I'll see you
next time
good
[Music]